[Music]
the marvel cinematic universe is getting
godly in phase four eternals the 26th
movie in the sprawling mcu is hitting
theaters in 2021 about a team of heroes
you may know nothing about he has
everything you need to know about
eternals and how the film fits into
marvel's phase 4.
you are about to meet the greatest
warriors the world has ever known
eternals was officially announced on
july 20 2019 at comic-con in san diego
with a slated premiere date of november
6 2020. unfortunately when the
coronavirus pandemic inevitably led to a
total reshuffling of the mcu slate
things changed with theaters around the
world shattered black widow ultimately
ended up being moved to may 2021 making
2020 the first year without a marvel
movie since 2009. eternals was given a
new release date of november 5th 2021.
fortunately this schedule actually stuck
marvel fans have been hearing news about
a film based on the eternals comics
being in the works since the spring of
2018 three and a half years later
they'll finally get to see him
[Music]
even longtime marvel fans might not be
too knowledgeable about who the eternals
are and their role in the marvel
universe after all they appeared in a
relatively limited run of comic books in
the mid-1970s and 80s the storyline was
revived for a mini-series by neil gaiman
in 2006 which brought these characters
into the modern marvel universe so who
are the eternals and what is their
significance according to marvel law an
alien species called the celestials
visited earth millions of years ago and
began carrying out experiments on the
inhabitants naturally the results of
these experiments weren't always a net
positive for our planet the celestials
were the original creators of the
eternals beings that looked like humans
yet possessed abilities like flight mind
reading and unbelievable strength and
endurance their superpowers and
resilience made them essentially
immortal and indestructible but the
celestial's experiments were also
responsible for the creation of the
deviants another group of humanoids who
were burdened with genetic mutations and
typically grotesque in appearance humans
mistook eternals for gods and the
eternals often clashed with the deviants
to protect humanity however the eternals
weren't unfailingly perfect as we'll
likely see in the film they can be
misled and insecure conflicts among
themselves
at this point we've met countless
characters from the original marvel
comics in the mcu have we been
introduced to any of the eternals yet
sort of it hasn't been mentioned in the
movies yet but thanos the most
formidable enemy of the avengers so far
was actually the child of eternals if
that seems a little confusing that's
understandable the eternals were
supposed to be protecting humanity not
wiping it out and they should be able to
physically blend in among humans however
it's safe to say that thanos was a bit
of a wild card because he also possessed
a recessive deviant gene which explains
his purply appearance obviously lots of
things can change in the journey from
the comics to the mcu so we wouldn't
necessarily use him as an example of the
eternals or deviants to come given that
the mcu has never shied away from
streamlining or changing its character's
dense histories for the screen it's
entirely possible that thanos comic
history as an eternal deviant hybrid may
not even come up
eternals actually shares a connection
with another film in the mcu in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 peter
quill's father ego tells peter that he
is a celestial
a celestial like a god
small g son
he's portrayed as extremely powerful and
possesses god-like abilities ego is
millions of years old and he is able to
manipulate the matter around him by the
time we meet him in guardians vol 2 he
has managed to form a whole planet
around himself but he can also inhabit a
human body yet all of this wasn't enough
for ego he eventually became bored with
mere immortality and decided that he
wanted to turn all of the wells and the
cosmos into extensions of himself but he
wasn't capable of doing this alone so he
needed another celestial to help him
turn his idea into reality that's
exactly why he became a father in the
first place he hoped his son pizza would
become his accomplice and to ensure that
his son wouldn't be led astray ego
killed peter's mother when peter found
out that ego was responsible for his
mother's death he turned against ego and
the guardians teamed up to destroy him
clearly the celestials can have
nefarious intentions and they're not an
all-powerful force for good in the
universe
the cast of eternals has rounded out
with both rising stars and a-listers
richard madden who rose to fame for
playing the ill-fated rob stark in game
of thrones has signed on to play icarus
icarus was known as the prime eternal in
the comics meaning that he was more
powerful than the other eternals he is
fueled by cosmic energy and he can move
at super speed and communicate
telepathically his sheer physical
strength and agility makes him a
formidable opponent in combat
what's this even made of vibranium
and speaking of game of thrones kit
harrington who is best known for playing
jon snow is in the eternals cast as dane
whitman whitman isn't an eternal himself
bertie is a superhero who goes by the
name the black knight and it's likely
that he'll have a prominent place in
future marvel films one way or another
you may not have heard of him but it's
worth mentioning that he's been a member
of the avengers and sometimes even the
team's leader for a very long time
who do you think is going to lead the
avengers
i could lead them
ridloff was born deaf and as one of the
few deaf actors in hollywood she has
always wanted to see more representation
for her community on screen now she's
made film history as the first
explicitly deaf superhero in the mcu her
casting also represents a major change
from the original comics her character
makari was actually a male character and
he wasn't written as death but the
reception to this change has been
overwhelmingly positive so far and fans
are generally looking forward to seeing
with love's portrayal of makari an
eternal with the power of super speed
angelina jolie plays the ageless eternal
athena in the eternals cast a major get
for the mcu to say the least in the
marvel universe the city of athens
greece was actually built for thena not
the goddess athena as most would
naturally assume and that's no
inconsequential mix-up human beings
confusing athena and athena bred
hostility between the eternals and the
olympic gods of greek mythology
eventually leading to an all-out war in
gaiman's eternals comics dina works as a
researcher at stark enterprises and
starts remembering her past as an
eternal through recurring nightmares
jolie is definitely the biggest name
attached to the eternals cast and maybe
the mcu in general and she's ecstatic to
be part of the evolving on-screen
universe speaking at san diego comic-con
she said i'm going to work 10 times
harder i know what we all need to do we
have all read the script we all know
what the task ahead is and we know what
you deserve so we are all going to be
working very very hard
when marvel initially revealed the main
eternals cast members at comic-con they
left audiences in suspense about who
would be playing cersei at disney's t23
expo it was announced that gemma chan
had landed the role as an eternal cersei
possesses powers like transmutation mind
control and flight however she also
loves living among humans she eventually
becomes a famous party planner in new
york city entertaining her guests with
magic that they believe is mere illusion
chan actually has a previous and related
role in the mcu as a cree warrior
minerva last seen getting blown up near
the end of captain marvel she's ecstatic
to be joining the eternals cast and
having the opportunity to play a new
character in the mcu posting on twitter
in 2019 i couldn't be happier to be
coming back to the mcu to play this
iconic character and to work with this
incredible group of people
chan isn't the only rising star joining
the eternal's cast at d23 it was
revealed that barry kyogin will
officially be playing druid druid does
have super powers but he doesn't use
them for good he's the villain of the
film wreaking havoc in the cosmos and on
earth kyogen has wanted to join the mcu
for a while in fact he even tweeted to
stan lee about it in 2013 writing stan
lee please make me a superhero now he's
finally achieved his goal kyogen caught
the attention of critics with his
performance as george mills in the
academy award winning film dunkirk and
went on to star in the psychological
thriller the killing of a sacred deer
most recently he played a role in two
episodes of the critically acclaimed hbo
series chernobyl druid definitely
represents a different type of role for
kyogen but clearly he's been waiting
years for a shot at landing apart in the
mcu now it's his time to shine
overall the cast of eternals is stacked
with a few other names new to superhero
derm that you'll probably recognize
kumeo nanjani will be playing kingo an
eternal with a day job as a major
bollywood star brian tyree henry will be
appearing as fastos who basically
develops all of the high-tech gear and
equipment that the eternals need in an
apparent first for marvel lebanese actor
haas slaymin will be appearing in
eternals as fast as his husband making
him one half of the first openly gay
relationship in the mcu
salma hayek has signed on to play ajak
who often has to serve as a diplomat
between the eternals and the celestials
this is because ajak was originally the
only eternal with the ability to
directly communicate with the celestials
don lee is taking on the role of
gilgamesh an eternal who in the comics
has fought alongside the avengers on
numerous occasions but has been
essentially overlooked until now finally
leah mchugh the youngest member of the
main cast is playing sprite as the name
suggests she's a mischievous trickster
whose pranks have always gotten her into
trouble
director chloe zhao will be at the helm
of eternals xiao is a newcomer to the
world of marvel these days of course
zhao is best known as the director of
nomadland the film won three academy
awards including best picture and best
director making zhao the second woman in
history to secure an oscar for directing
zhao's history as an indie filmmaker
turned oscar winner makes her an
interesting choice for the director of
eternals this film definitely represents
a new artistic direction for the
filmmaker but there's no doubt that the
movie is in good hands
young syrian actor zain arafiya has a
supporting role in eternals and it may
be a significant one while he only
appears briefly in the movie's teaser
and trailer apparently as a prehistoric
human salma hayek posted a photo with
liam mchugh and al-rafia with the
caption hanging with the eternal's youth
al-rafia himself hinted that he might be
playing neymar the submariner an
atlantean prince and mutant time will
tell whether or not these rumors have
any truth to them but if eternals opens
a door to marvel's undersea kingdom and
the story of the first mutant it would
be even more of a must-see movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]